the next battlefield game has been
revealed and the rumors were true it's
going back to World War one that means
Zeppelin's horses by planes and
battleships we've got plenty of
information about the multiplayer and
single-player campaign too I'm Tony this
is a game spot news update and this is
battlefield one so what can you expect
from battlefield ones multiplayer 64
player battles will extend across land
air and sea you're going to have the
automatic and bolt action rifles you
expect but you'll also be able to
destroy your opponents with battleships
and bombers melee combat has been
reworked as well letting you duke it out
in the trenches with bayonets sabers
trench clubs and even shovels and if you
need to get around in a hurry you can
always jump on the back of a motorcycle
or a horse as for single-player
battlefield one will take you all over
the world from the deserts of Arabia to
the snowy Italian Alps levels will also
have much more choice and variety than
in previous Battlefield games as each
story character deals with a changing
world in their own way battlefield one
will be playable first on Xbox one and
PC through EA access starting october
18th the full release on xbox one pc and
ps4 is October 21st we've got tons more
information over at gamespot to keep up
with all the latest battlefield news
you're definitely in the right place